on est en installation couchage en fait
on a une grande remorque qui est bâchée
et dans lequel dedans on va faire un
dortoir de manière à ce qu'il y ait le
plus de personnes possibles pour se
tenir le plus chaud possible Anton
ouvre la bachche s'il te
plaît ah j'ai pas pris les petits draps
et tout he les gars désolé alors moi je
suis venu avec un collègue à moi donc
avec ce tracteur là moi je suis salar
agricole dans le valdoise à côté de
manonvecin dans une exploitation de
policulture j'ai 28 ans j'ai
pour projet si possible de m'installer
plus tard sur une exploitation c'est
quand même une passion j'ai peut-être 10
tracteur avant de dire papa donc oui on
est assez effrayé par tout ça en fait
nous en tant que jeune il en reste ou
pas ouais bah c'est comme ça que ça va
se passer sur ce point de blocage donc
sur la 15 on est au moins 50 tracteurs
donc ce qui est quand même relativement
bien ave tous partis du Vexin français
et puis là on est vraiment là pour une
durée totalement
indéterminé on a un petit peu tout notre
camp de base ici donc on a notre
restauration qui va être là-bas où on a
nos barnom et là on va avoir donc le
dortoir on va avoir tout ce qui est
barbecue on a le groupe électrogène qui
est ici également et puis là dans la
remorque donc on a de la palette on a du
bois pour tenir le plus de jours
possible ça va vraiment être de la
survie tant qu'on pourra tant que il
faudra qu'on soit
là alors là on a quand même un nombre de
revendications en fait mais déjà on
aimerait qu'on arrive à sortir des
salaires adéquates par rapport à ce
qu'on fournit comme comme travail qu'on
aimerait que on arrête d'avoir une
concurrence déloyale en fait avec les
autres pays de l'Union européenne et on
aimerait aussi qu'il y ait beaucoup
moins de norme puisque l'agriculture
française est normée encore plus que
l'agriculture européenne on arrive au
bout d'une chaîne où on en peut plus
surtout quand on voit qu'on importe de
pays étrangers des choses qui sont mais
totalement interdites de faire en France
le CB est bien installé on peut enfin
s'asseoir se poser une petite bière de
décontraction sans abuser et après je
pense qu'après on va pouvoir commencer à
penser à merci beaucoup hop là au
barbecue et nous servons de la bière du
valdoise qui est la bière du Vexin
celle-ci elle est pas importée c'est du
local donc là il faut pas penser que
j'ai été barman dans une autre vie j'ai
juste un petit peu une belle vie
étudiante comment fait pour organiser
just ah en fait au niveau du syndicat on
a deséf qui un petit peu donne à chacun
la tâche ce qu'il faut amener comme
matériel et puis après une fois qu'on a
tout réuni et ben on s'organise sur
place et c'est là que tous mone comme il
faut aujourd'hui on est tous regroupés
pour les mêmes problématiques une
exploitation qui ne fait même pas un
hectare et une exploitation qui fait
1000 hectares est pas impacté par la
même chose mais tous les modèle agricole
sont touchés par ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle je pense que des
arboriculteurs comme des sérialiers
comme des e des March comme des éleveurs
tout le monde un impact et je pense
qu'on peut éalement dire quand on voit
dans les pays étrangers ça bouge
également c'est parce que l'riculture
européenne a des choses à
réviserier tout le monde comme il
faut j' petite grille quietourne comme
ça que tout le temp du blocageura tout
le temps du monde comme l'ont dit tout à
l'heure responsable l'idéal sera 30
personnes àure sur
blocage et je pense que c'est ce qui est
largement jouable on devrait être
rejoint par des par des collègues
d'autres régions
donc il y a des tracteurs en plus qui
arrivent demain dès demain dès demain
donc et puis on risque d'avoir des
autocars qui vont venir d'autres région
donc ça va faire un petit peu de petit
peu d'animation sur le camp on espère
réellement avoir des réponses cohérentes
à nos demandes et avoir une écoute du
gouvernement par rapport à tout ce qu'on
leur demande moi j'espère qu'il va y
avoir un grand virage et que ils vont
enfin se rendre compte qu'on est mais un
maillon essentiel et de l'économie euh
et du territoire va falloir un petit peu
plus de main d'œuvre au barbecue s'il
vous plaît les personnes qui n'ont pas
forcément de budget dans l'alimentation
ils vont se tourner vers ce qui va être
le moins cher et le moins cher à l'heure
actuelle c'est ce qui a le moins de
charge donc ce qui vient de l'étranger
donc il va peut-être falloir commencer
par ce maillon là avant d'aller avant
d'aller chercher des des idées
complètement à côté de la plaque donc là
on a une première chambre il faut se le
dire comme on risque de rester quand
même euh plusieurs jours plusieurs nuits
on a quand même prévu ce qu'il fallait
tac si on y arrive on va se brancher
électricité parce qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut on a le raccordement comme ça on va
pouvoir mettre le chauffage et puis
c'est pas le froid du mois de de la fin
janvier qui va nous faire peur si on
doit poursuivre jusqu'en février il y a
aucun problème moi je suis de famille
agricole j'ai plusieurs générations
devant moi c'est pas évident d'arriver à
se projeter euh par rapport à leur récit
moi mon grand-père il a quand même
commencé avec ses chevaux c'était cé une
époque où il fallait produire produire
produire parce queil fallait redonner à
manger aux Français euh mon oncle il
s'est installé dans les années 90
euh ben on commençait déjà à dire bah
ces produits là il faudrait peut-être
les mettre de côté et puis c'est aussi
la période où commençait à s'intensifier
un petit peu le marché international
donc c'était un petit peu moins facile
de se positionner mais c'était encore
des années où l'riculture française ils
arrivaient à se projeter on sait plus
sur quel pied danser on sait plus non
plus
si on doit investir parce que pour ce
l'agriculture il faut quand même se le
dire il y a tout le temps des projets de
renouveau d'amélioration est-ce que là
il faut le
faire c'est une petite apparté mais à
l'heure actuelle un tracteur chez un
agriculteur ça ne lui appartient pas ça
appartient à une banque et un tracteur
ça vaut le prix d'une maison et donc
est-ce que je le fais est-ce que je le
fais pas est-ce que je me je me mets
dans la merde pendant 7 ans est-ce que
ah bah si bah là cette année c'est
prometteur allez je signe et l'année
d'après
on trébuchche et on sait pas ce qu'on
doit continuer à faire donc je pense que
si on narrive pas à nous à nous donner
des des bonnes réponses bah on va
continuer à être incapable de se
projeter il peut pas partir sa voiture
elle est bloquée entre les
voitures'a dit c'est bon je peux partir